Mà chúng ta không thể bắt kinh người mà thích nhập bình trường để chờ lâu khi giá nhà của Cóc Cóc
cho phạch là hàng sang của Thủ xuống để mua được.
Sau với lệnh bình khúc, những người mà thích nhập mới ra chờ của các bạn,
ý, chúng ta đang thấy rằng là cái giá nhà với gạng,
cái mất cứ nhập của người dân, xuống đông.
Nó đang có sự chân lệnh và chúng ta vẫn bất nhiều năm,
chúng ta mới có hàng đăng dệ mua được nhà.
Nhưng mà lúc ấy tôi nghĩ như thế này,
nếu chúng ta mạng đề tâm đồng ra sau sánh thì tôi thấy ra nhà hàng.
Mình nếu chúng ta mạng đề gạng, ra sau sánh thì tôi thấy là bạn mới có thích sản là ăn từ lộ.
Vậy thì nếu mà sau sánh đứng vạn với lệnh của mình sản thì 2 cái đầu đông của thăng đông.
Lâu có lệnh nhau rồi, đúng không?
Chẳng qua là nó có video liển,
là ở đây là mình thì phía chương găng chỉ có những người con khúc sánh cho tự lực chú liệu.
Trên nhiều người thấy cái nền giá nó cào.
Hãy là một số tên 1, 2 mình nhìn càng nó 3 mình có 4 mình nhìn càng nhờ mình,
mình rất mọi người ở đây, cho chúng cấp phó phía chương thột.
Thì càng ra con tự tính ra tuổi nhìn.
Cái cái quả ra là cái nó sẽ tệ trả nền.
Nhưng nền tập con nghe là giá khá bột có cấp thì hạng sản là tập.
Nhưng mà chúng ta không thể không thể bắt kinh người mà thích nực mình chưa ăn để
cho lợi khi giá nhà của cấp, học là thẳng sáng là khu xuống để mua được ngờ gồm đi.
Nó là khu khách.
Dạy phá này, chêu khách của con khách là chỉ có với giá trang khách trên bột xuống pin của công kio và giá hội.
Nó là nhờ mình rất, và nhờ chúng cấp rất chúng cấp.